[Music]
today's median demonstrated once again
that the European Union and Egypt are
key partners and that Egypt sustainable
stability and economic development is
vital for all of us we have established
close a combination in many areas
notably on socio-economic development on
scientific research energy migration
country in terrorism and as I mentioned
regional issues we the European Union
the member states recalled the EU s
clear interest in Egypt sustainable
stability and security as well as the
fact that establishing a modern and
democratic state is essential in this
regard the EU member states reaffirmed
their strong interest in continuing to
pursue the partnership with Egypt and I
would like to personally thank the
minister for having led his delegation
Egypt has submitted projects related to
the partnership priorities and is
looking forward to implementation
because they will have a very pertinent
effect on Egypt's economic reform
program we had a frank discussion as
relates the issues of democracy
governance human rights we also of
course discussed the pressing regional
issues that are of strategic interests
both to Egypt and countries of the
Middle East and Europe over the past 18
months I think the focus of you Egypt
cooperation has been on supporting
Egypt's economic social and political
development to improve the prospects of
its people and contribute to
stabilization and long term prosperity
of the country but also of the whole
region the partnership biologists have
set the basis for further strengthening
of you Egypt cooperation notably for
economic reforms and houston's ready to
support all the reforms aimed at
attracting investment
you
[Music]